president biden says the texas abortion
law is an un-american vigilante system
the supreme court has refused to stop
the new regulations and that's
intensifying democratic efforts to
change the makeup of the high court and
get rid of the senate filibuster white
house correspondent peter ducey has the
latest on that tonight
i have been continue to be
a strong supporter of roe v wade and
before roe v wade is challenged in front
of the supreme court president biden is
worried because they just upheld a texas
law restricting abortions the most
pernicious thing about the texas law
it sort of creates a vigilante system
where people get rewards to go out
anyway
and it just seems i know this sounds
ridiculous almost un-american
progressives have had it aoc tweets
republicans promised to overturn roe v
wade and they have democrats can either
abolish the filibuster and expand the
court or do nothing some progressives
have already outlined how they do it we
undo the damage the republicans have
done by restoring balance and we do it
by passing the judiciary act of 2021 to
add four seats to the court to create a
13-member supreme court the president
describes himself as a student of
history and has historically been
against expanding the court like when
fdr tried he violated no law
he was legalistically absolutely correct
but it was a bonehead idea but as
president he has ordered a commission of
experts to brief him on the pros and
cons of court packing and his mind is
open the president doesn't have any new
thoughts on the structure of the clerk
he's waiting for the conclusion of this
report looks forward to reviewing it
seeing where they come out if the
president decides he wants to add four
spots to the court and fill them with
progressives he's gonna have to do it
while democrats control congress which
could make the fight ahead of the
upcoming midterms the equivalent of a
quadruple kavanaugh mike
peter ducey in the white house briefing
room peter thanks a lot hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else